Now, just to give you a review of scoring if you aren't familiar with the rules.
The letters score their value--the number that's on them--times whatever you've placed them on
if that's a double or triple letter score.
Here I don't have any double or triple letter scores, so I get the individual values of the letters--
10, 11, 12, 22--times the total word multiplier,
and the pink square are double word scores,
so that's a double multiplier--22 times 2 is 44 points for that.
Then if the next play goes here, it has to connect.
Now, this was a double word, but I don't get any double, because I didn't actually place
a new tile over an existing double word, so nothing is doubled,
but I do get credit for the Z, even though I didn't place the Z.
I get credit for that as 10, not as 20 as it originally scored, but as its face value--
10 plus 1--this is a triple 1, so that's plus 3 plus 1--10, 11, 14, 15.
Then if the next play, say, was here, that would just a score 3, 4, 5.
I didn't have any bonuses whatsoever.
This bonus here doesn't count, because I didn't play over it.
If a bonus is already covered up, it doesn't county any more, so this would just be 5.
One more scoring rule.
If this is the word on the board--great play putting the Q on a double letter
and a double word as well--this would score 20--1, 2, 3, 4 times 2 is 48.
The next play could be this, which simultaneously forms 3 words--
NO in this direction and then IN and NO in this direction.
For NO, we'd get a double letter is 2 plus 1 is 3.
For IN, we get just 1 plus 1, so that's 3 plus 2 is 5.
And for NO we get another 3, so that would be a score of 8 altogether.
Here is calculate_score. It takes all these variables that we need to specify the play.
We're going to start out a total of my word multiplier--
that is, have I got any double or triple letters, and there might be more than one of them.
If I had a long word that matches up with some existing letters on the board,
then I'd get credit, and if. I covered a double and a triple letter, then I'd multiply by 6
I need to keep track of that. Then I also want to keep track of the cross word totals.
Not the word I'm playing but the other cross words, but they are separate from this word multiplier.
Figure out where my starting position is from that position.
Figure out the direction that I'm moving in--down or across--what the delta are.
Figure out what the other direction is.
If I'm moving in the cross direction, I want to know that the other direction is the down direction.
Now just enumerate the words.
Enumerate the letters in the word and the position within the word.
Figure out the square on the board and the bonus squares, the word multiplier,
if the square was already placed on the board,
so if it is a letter--and I've got a function for that.
I should be defining this here, so this is a bad piece code.
I should be calling is_letter(sq) rather than testing directly,
since is decided to make that more abstract.
Figure out the word multiplier from the bonuses.
You only get the bonus if the letter wasn't already on the board.
Figure out the letter multipler--same thing.
Increment my points by the points from the letter times the letter multiplier,
and now if the square is an anchor and the anchor is not one of these unrestricted anchors,
then we want to look for the cross words.
If there is a cross word, figure out the cross word score and add that into the total.
Why do I have this direction is not down here?
Because I'm going to do--cross word score is going to recursively calculate score,
and we don't want it to recurse infinitely. We just want it to recurse once.
To explain that a little bit more, note up here in horizontal_plays we're calling calculate _score,
so the only place we call calculate_score is here, and we're calling it with the across.
The way we get the down is because we transpose the board.
So for calculate score, we know we're going to be called with the across direction the first time
and then the down direction the second time.
Although, I guess I feel a little bit bad that that assumption that we're always going to be called
with across the first time is kind of hardwired into this.
That makes calculate_score a little bit brittle.
Probably, I should refactor this to stop the recursion in some other way.
But I'm so close to the finish line now I don't want to stop to clean things up.
I want to get to the end.
Here is crosswordscore. Figure out the position.
We find the cross word. That's a function we already wrote.
Then we recursively call calculate_score.